hey guys it's max from axe set today
we're gonna be doing a comparison
between the brand new pixel 3a XL and
the iPhone 10 R we'll be taking a look
at the build quality and design the LCD
displays we're gonna do a speaker
comparison and check out the performance
if you want to check that out make sure
you guys stick around first off thank
you to Google for sending this to us as
part of Team pixel we definitely
appreciate it
let's get this thing unboxed and jump
right into it okay so first impressions
feel in the hand it's interesting you
can definitely tell it's plastic it
feels kind of lightweight
I don't know how light it is or how
heavy it is compared to the iPhone 10 or
maybe we'll put it right above here but
it does feel light and this little
texture feels kind of similar to the
glass texture that they have on the
standard pixel 3 but then of course when
you touch the top part and especially
the sides you could definitely tell that
it's plastic now along with this phone
in the box we did not get any headphones
Nikon 10 R does include headphones but
we do have an 18 watt charger that is
crazy compared to the 5 watt that comes
even with the $1100 iPhone 10 s max
that's definitely awesome that Google is
shipping a proper charger even with a
$400 phone with that said when I hold
both of these in my hands there's no
doubt about it that the iPhone 10 R
feels much more premium given that it
has glass back and aluminum sides with
that glass back we also have wireless
charging and we also have waterproofing
both those things are missing with the
pixel 3/8 keep in mind that if you're
gonna be using a case the plastic build
quality doesn't matter at all because
you won't feel it so here I have the
fabric case of the Google also sent
along with it and it does feel pretty
nice in the hands and then even though I
have the black phone I still get the
little off coloured button with the case
comparing the size they are actually
very similar the width is basically the
same the thickness is also basically the
same but the pixel 3a XL is taller
because it does have the chin and a
little forehead just like the flash if
we also have a fingerprint scanner on
the back so let's set this thing up and
see how fast it is
so it's not as fast as a galaxy s 10 II
but it's definitely not a slouch and I
think a part of it might be the
animation of what kind of fading in I
would probably have to say that the
pixel three might be slightly faster
they're close since Google decided to
stick with OLED for its budget devices
we have this always-on display which I
definitely appreciate being able to see
the time and some notifications without
having to turn on the device of course
Typhon 10r uses an LCD display so that
is not possible let's jump to the home
page and compare the displays the iPhone
10 RS 6.1 inches compared to six with a
three Axl but if we set the display
side-by-side the iPhones is just
slightly taller because we have these
little extra kind of bunny ears or
whatever you want to call them showing
us some information but the pixel
display is actually slightly wider
because as thinner bezels let's compare
the brightness I have auto brightness
shut off on both and I maxed them out
and they look very similar to me at
least at a perfect angle the white
balance also looks almost identical but
that is with true tone turned on if I go
ahead and shut off true tone now we can
see that the iPhones LCD screen is much
cooler letting our camera sensor decide
Vadim is saying that the iPhone is
brighter I have these maxed out and if
you look from our side camera angle
you'll see how much dimmer the iPhone is
now let's compare the display quality of
a really nice YouTube video open right
here looking at these two there's
literally no comparison as far as the
displays you can definitely tell the
difference in sharpness and detail in
how punchy the colors are and with
brightness as well so both these are
playing by 1080p video but of course the
pixel has a much higher pixel density
and it really shows off here and one
very interesting thing is that the pixel
3a is showing up as HDR that's weird
because in the comparison tool google
lists the pixel 3 the flagships is HDR
but they don't put HDR for these phones
so the pixel clearly has the better
display but one area where it really
falls behind is the processor and the
graphics the iPhone 10 R has Apple's
flagship a 12 Bionic processor whereas
the pixel 3a devices have the stop track
670 which is a mid-range processor here
in Geekbench 4 you can tell the iPhones
multi-core score is basically double and
the single core score is about triple
testing an two to the overall score is
basically double same with the CPU score
and looking at graphics back when 10 RS
graphics is more than twice as high and
when we ran the test you could see that
the iPhone is perfectly smooth but the
pixel 3 is super choppy so if you're
gonna be playing games the iPhone is
definitely the better choice as far as
battery life both of these are gonna be
quite good the iPhone 10 R has a low res
display which helps with battery life
but the battery is about 29 50 milliamp
hours compared to 3700 with a pixel 3/8
XL but with that one benefit with the
pixel 3a is that you get that 18 watt
fast charger so if you are low on
battery life you can quickly charge up
this one also has 4 gigabytes of RAM
just like the pixel 3 compared to 3
gigabytes but Android is not as
efficient and the pixel 3 had some
issues where older apps would shut down
even turning off your music when you
wanted to take a picture Google has to
dress some of those with software but
I'll just have to wait and see I will be
doing a full review of this phone so if
you guys want to check that out and see
how it is after I've used it for about a
week go ahead and hit that subscribe
button and enable those notifications
now it's time for a speaker comparison
we know that the iPhones sound pretty
good and the pixel 3 sounded fantastic
with their dual speakers but with the
pixel 3 a google got rid of the dual
front-facing we still have stereo but
one of them is now bottom firing just
like the iPhones let's go ahead and
compare them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that was definitely unexpected the
iPhone has kind of louder myths whereas
the pixel 3a has more kind of dynamic
range especially in the highs the high
notes really stand out and there's a lot
of separation between little electronic
sounds or the instruments there so I if
I have to choose one I probably would
choose the pixel but it's very very
close you guys let me know in the
comment section which one you think
sounded better to you finally let's
finish off by comparing the cameras both
of these have a single camera on the
back and on the front so the pixel 3 no
longer has the dual cameras but if we
compare these selfies you could see how
much wider the selfie camera is on the
pixel and here's some side-by-side shots
with the rear cameras both are fantastic
and it's really up to you which one you
prefer I generally like the colors and
contrast from the iPhone photos but one
difference that you can't dispute is
that the pixel will take portrait shots
of just about anything compared to the
iPhone 10 art which only takes portrait
photos of people the pixel also has the
nitesite feature which takes amazing
photos in practically no light at all
but if you're a video shooter the iPhone
performs much better compared to the
pixel phones so overall I'm very
impressed with a pixel three eight and
three axl Google is doing a genius move
by giving us such a nice phone with a
great display and with that same camera
from its pixel three for just $400 or
480 dollars I think this is gonna sell
very well I think reps at all of these
local carriers are gonna be really
pushing this phone it's gonna give
Google a nice heads up now the iPhone
does have some areas that it really
performs better than the pixel of course
if you want us you're gonna have to go
with an iPhone but if you're an Android
user this thing is such a great value if
you guys want to see twelve features
that are missing out of the pixel 3a
phones compared to the flagship pixel
threes click that little video over
there if you guys want to see our
upcoming comparisons and the full review
click that little circle to subscribe
and go ahead and click right there to
enable notifications spin Mac Mac sec
and I'll see you in the next video where
as the iPhone is limited to just humans
I'll say that again